hello I'm on this deaf guy remember it
so you don't have to we only have been
an interesting time because of our
internet culture don't we most of us
just go online for either business or
pleasure but then there's another two
groups of people we're all too familiar
with those looking to offend and those
looking to be offended admit it we've
all come across these people and they're
both pains in the ass extremists trolls
looking to get attention by pissing
people off and extremist crybabies
looking to get attention by acting like
everything everywhere is an insult
we usually shrug or lap them off and
then go on with our lives but the
combination of the two extremes has led
to an interesting issue being addressed
our humor some would argue humor has
gone way too far
driving too much into bad taste and
harsh stereotypes others would say humor
has gone too soft afraid to anger the
politically correct sensitivities of the
world are either of them right do any of
them hold any water well first of all
offensive comedy is nothing new
comedians have been censored harassed
even sent to jail for jokes that today
would be seen as pretty commonplace
that's because as mentioned by myself
and others all comedy is based on some
form of misery so you always have to
address something unpleasant in order to
get a laugh George Carlin one of the
world's most beloved rule breakers once
said comedy doesn't work unless
someone's getting offended that he's
right puns are a mockery of language
goofy faces are a mockery of
strange-looking people you really have
to think about it but yeah somebody's
pride has to be challenged in order for
it to work but what most comedians
realize is the more truth in pain you
can emphasize usually the more funny it
is Tom and Jerry is much funnier than
Smurfs because it really looks like the
pain hurts malcolm in the middle' is
much funnier than full house because
they address much harsher realities but
of course if you were to see any of
these in real life you probably be
horrified and one laugh at all
hence this is why comedy is a defense
mechanism which I go more into in other
editorials but this begs the question
when does a joke go too far why is it
okay when Dave Chappelle uses the n-word
but not okay when somebody else uses it
like
oh you know my ass you see mother Papa
yeah too many of us this might seem
pretty fucking obvious what the
difference is but like in many cases you
need an extreme to understand an extreme
so we'll just use this one as an example
when Richards used the word it wasn't a
laugh at a problem or offer an
interesting point of view his intent was
to seriously hurt a person Wish Appel he
uses the exact same word but he's
mocking such hate he's using it as a
means of satire and to get people to
look at an issue both were trying to
make the audience laugh but one came
from a place of trying to do something
positive while the other came from a
place of trying to do something negative
so does it simply come down to intent
not entirely Gilbert Godfrey got in
trouble when he made tsunami jokes
shortly after a massive Japanese
earthquake it even ended up costing him
his voiceover job for Aflac now tsunami
jokes weren't nothing new but when was
made just after that real-life event the
pain would still do clothes for most
people this is why most people say
comedy is pain plus time we've all heard
Titanic jokes or Lincoln assassination
jokes but if you were to make those
shortly after the event it would be seen
as insensitive because you wouldn't be
taking into consideration the pain
others are going through this is where
the phrase too soon comes from Gottfried
eventually apologized as you realize he
crossed the line there wasn't enough
positivity to the joke in order to make
people laugh that doesn't make him a bad
person and his career would still do
fine but many would agree that joke hurt
more than it healed some comedians
however thrive on bad taste there's
people like Matt Stone and Trey Parker
and to a lesser extent Seth MacFarlane
who make no qualms that they want to try
anything funny and don't care who gets
offended in the process well both can be
entertaining most find themselves
enjoying stone and Parker's humor more
but why they both seem focused on shock
value and what's inappropriate part of
it may come from the fact that their
most popular project South Park and Book
of Mormon instill trust that its
creators can be goofy but also have a
balanced mindset the extremism seems
like an excuse to apply common sense
into a world of madness something a lot
of us can identify with and see a lot of
comedy in Seth MacFarlane's work it's
always a mean crazy person in a mean
crazy world
comedy seems less balanced and more
desperate to shock nowhere is that more
obvious than with the joke about Sarah
Palin's child I think it's actually kind
of confusing a family guy Chris goes on
a date with a girl who has Down syndrome
and she says her mother is the former
governor of Alaska Palin got so pissed
and caused others to make a big fuss
about it but to me the biggest insult is
the joke doesn't make sense
Palin has a son with Down syndrome are
they implying that former governors of
Alaska have Down syndrome kids are they
saying the son got a sex change and
suddenly became a teenager really fast
the joke is such a cheap shot at shock
humor that people got offended by it
before they even asked if they really
got it that's an example of humor
looking to shock just for the sake of
shock value now that's not to say it
can't be funny or even downright
hilarious at times but it's not going to
hit as Mabel's eyes at South Park as
we've seen the past couple years because
we've relate with Parker and stones
humor more and therefore trust them more
so even the art of bad taste is still an
art nonetheless but what about when it
goes the other direction when not being
too offensive kills the comedy but being
too politically correct kills the comedy
remember when they ban Speedy Gonzales
for a while yeah this was actually a
thing so many people were offended and
said he was a bad Mexican stereotype
that is except for one group of people
fucking Mexicans yeah they thought Feeny
was fine there was nothing wrong with
him eventually too many complaints
saying they wanted to see him back that
that's exactly what they did and now
he's back in the regular Looney Tunes
lineup those getting offended for a
group of people I wasn't even offended
Jerry Seinfeld once made a joke about
models looking pissed on the runway and
people were shelling sexist at it in
fact he stopped playing at college
campuses because audiences were too
sensitive to his material college
campuses were too sensitive to the most
Vennela stand-up you can think of I
thought colleges were supposed to be
wild and crazy a bunch of party people
Jerry Seinfeld was too extreme for you
Christ they'd probably faint of rapi
when I stage Amy Poehler one of
america's funniest performers and
feminist icon did a sitcom on who about
a comedian who leads the profession
because her colleagues say too many
offensive jokes yes what happened
twitter got offended at the offensive
jokes
they were supposed to find offensive
Christ is that kind of like saying you
know I know I'm not supposed to like the
Nazis but the way you represent them
they just seemed a little too mean these
were a little too mean for Nazis these
aren't the only comedians that have
noticed it there's a brilliant key and
peele sketch where a company vice
president asked a black man a white
woman and a gay man to listen to a
speech to make sure it's not offensive
they made dozens of complaints about how
offended they are before he even gets to
the speech when he finally does begin
the speech he says a Chinaman a Pollock
and an Arab walk into a bar and of
course the three of them have no problem
and I think that sketch gets to why
there's such an extreme between people
who are looking to offend and people who
are looking to be offended it all comes
from where we place our emotions we
still live in an online culture where
you can be ambiguous and therefore your
actions don't really have any punishment
not everybody abuses this like a
psychopath but many use the internet as
a means to get out aggression and
frustration that everybody feels in
their lives of course if you do it in a
healthy way that's not hurting anybody
there's nothing wrong with it at least
if you realize that's what you're doing
socially awkward people looking for fast
attention usually become trolls or pick
pointless fights and forums and we all
see them for all swear words and slurs
and pretty much as ignore them but then
there's people looking to fight for a
cause which is fine causes are good they
set change in motion and let the world
know when it's time to correct something
but if you go into a cause for a wrong
reason say to fulfill an emotional even
selfish need you're gonna probably be
making the cause look bad if you're
fighting for something to fill a void
and not because you want actual change
you're liable to be more emotional and
closed-minded to the subject this can
also lead to seeing scenarios that
aren't really there
remember when Michael Jackson said one
of his albums didn't sell because Sony
was racist uh yeah that must be it
remember when males feeb called Disney a
sexist anti-semite even though there has
never been any evidence to prove so and
not to bring a palin again but remember
when she turned feminist for just a few
minutes claiming that the reason
everybody was picking on her was because
she was a woman
that you've given us no other reason to
possibly make fun of you all of these
are good causes race religion gender
equality of all of them as we're
fighting for but pent up emotion can
explode at the wrong time and at the
wrong people leading us to demonize
perfectly good ideas or causes don't
worry we're not going to be short of
racist sexist bigoted assholes out there
you don't need to go searching for them
where they don't exist and you don't
need to destroy go comedy for it either
in reality the best way to cause change
isn't a soft and humor but rather
increase humor great comedians like John
Oliver Stephen Colbert and Jon Stewart
have become the most trusted people in
media not because they wave their
fingers and complain but because they
apply humor satire and common sense to
facts that really matter but let's be
honest it's the comedy that draws us in
we listen to him first because they're
funny then because they're dealing with
our truths
look at John Oliver on YouTube he's
fucking exploding lots of people are
getting interested in subjects that they
never would have been interested in
before but because he makes them so
funny and so interesting you'd rather
listen to him than some stick-in-the-mud
on Twitter but if we're to go by the no
comedy can be offensive guidelines then
not only would we lose these incredible
truths but also the great comedians that
made it possible so then should we never
be offended by anything no there are
people and jokes there trying to spread
more hate and despair rather than joy
and change and we took all about on it
but does that mean we should list the
things we can talk about and the things
we can't talk about of course not that'd
be against free speech and limiting our
growth
remember when we were offended by Bart
Simpson on TV or Madonna or any of these
other people
these were shocking icons that we're
gonna destroy our generation and now
they're just commonplace people barely
even give a shit about him anymore but
they evolved us to an area where this
could be commonplace and talk about
subjects that need to be talked about so
then how do we know who to get offended
by and who not to get offended by well
sadly the answer is not in any book and
it's not online you just have to use
common sense I think most of us get a
pretty strong feeling that louis c.k and
Chris Rock don't use their offensive
comedy out of mean-spiritedness
they use it to make you laugh and bring
out a strong point we're comedians like
Carlos Mencia and Andrew Dice Clay
probably do use it out of
mean-spiritedness aren't funny and
that's why they didn't last very long
you will get on a bus to go to the
Million Man March but you won't get on a
bus to get away from
patrina you just have to use your
intuition does your gut say that deep
down they're really prejudice or sexist
or whatever will we always be right
probably not there's certainly people we
trusted before they've let us down and
it's even good comedian that crossed the
line because comedy is a tricky
tightrope but it's a tightrope that
needs to be walked and we need to slip
up sometimes every comedian does it
shows how far we could go and how far we
probably shouldn't go and it also shows
that we can make wrong steps but through
the positivity that made us likable to
begin with we can get back on track some
do this beautifully others not so much
but if the alternative is fear and judge
everything then comedy will be dead very
quickly so still push the envelope of
what's not accepted and still fight for
what's worth fighting for
just be sure that you're communicating
it with the right intention because the
cost isn't worth the price of all things
the 90s show duck man might have made
the most brilliant comments about comedy
ever it's when a comedian comes in
claiming he wants to do humor that
doesn't offend anyone so this medical
caregiver of indeterminate gender
because nurses can be male or female
says through his or her disabled or
should I say differently-abled patient
you get the idea but when he
surprisingly becomes a big hit our hero
comes along it says some of the most
poignant words ever about the importance
of comedy they're actually so good that
I think it only fit Stan in the
editorial with it this precisely when
humor is offensive that we need it most
comedy should provoke it should bless
through prejudices challenge
preconceptions comedy should always
leave you different than what it found
you sure humor can hurt even alienate
but the risk is better than the
alternative demand to be challenged to
be offended to be treated like thinking
reasoning adults a duck voice by Jason
Alexander just said one of the most
important things ever this is why comedy
is so great I'm honest our critic I
remember it so you don't have to
hey guys dog walker here as I said in
the past I'm gonna end these videos with
a shout out to a different charity each
week and this week we are doing the
Ronald McDonald House Charities this is
actually a charity we've worked with a
couple times in the past and they do
wonderful work in supplying people and
children especially who need help who
are sick and they do their best to give
them a place where they can go and they
can have help and they can have medical
attention and they can have support and
they can have people who are so kind and
so caring and again we've seen a lot of
this firsthand and these are just such
kind awesome wonderful people and as I
said before we've we've done work with
them before and we've done charity
drives and they are just a wonderful
group that are working for such a good
good cause just to give children as well
as adults just a place to feel home a
place to feel safe when they're going
through all sorts of really tough things
and it's a wonderful fantastic
foundation to check out you can check it
out at the address here they do
wonderful work they are so awesome at
what they do and you know you can of
course just give at the McDonald's you
know they always have the little box
there but it means so much more if you
go to the website see what they do and
maybe open up your heart a little bit
more because they definitely do very
very good work so definitely if you get
a chance go check them out